hey mister DJ everybody is ready to
party I agree and I think the DJ is
about to get the whole internet party
see I talk a lot about creating content
and you know find your voice written
audio or maybe even video like some of
us but a lot of people are scared off by
that and maybe don't feel that they can
do it and I understand that not
everybody's out there to do that
and over the temple past years it's
become very obvious to me that the DJ
business is very lucrative see we're
people we have so much information being
thrown at us now in this little computer
and the new one I just brought over here
um because I want to start live
streaming more often so um sorry that we
need people to aggregate for us I mean
let's look at all the people that are
being massively successful out there and
I think the Mitch DJ is about to explode
I mean if I put it aside called wine
today and every day spent a couple hours
reading wine stuff and that six or seven
links of maybe even my own content on
top of them like maybe a two sentence
play on my social commentating that
would become quite a substantial visited
site over time and would allow me to
probably monetize those eyeballs at some
level now I have some thoughts on that
long term but over the next 48 to 60
months I think the DJ business is gonna
be massively lucrative so if you find
yourself out there being very passionate
about a subject and go very niche
because there's a lot I'm out there but
if you want to get into the DJ game if
you want to agregate a lot of links that
may be Sony commentate on top of them
and then get into the
Frenchy's with your community and do all
the other things we talked about I think
the DJ game is huge I think a lot of
people gonna win there's so many sites
out there that I would visit if they
aggregated all the Jets content we're
seeing it done all the time and I think
there's a huge play out there so if you
want to be in the DJ business if you
want to take all the songs or all the
content in this manner and then put it
out there and maybe add some content a
sentence or two why you went there
I think there's a little money making
content play for you it's obvious and
it's an opportunity and the DJ is gonna